look at sobe music instrument net mesh
opposites Martin Luther girls traveling
and a Lutheran with him
the german pastor Gerhard hegler has
been called to Russia together with his
companion racial figure I hope he gets
to st. Petersburg in one piece for
pastor heckler it's a dream come true
this is not his first visit to some
Petersburg McQueen remind about his
vision you're both places are home to me
Germany and st. Petersburg
but then your new home loser i Mudd was
it welcome pastor Hitler we've been
expecting you my goodness who've we got
there
this is where the story begins in the
little town of zaire hime in Germany two
months before passed a heckler set off
with Luther for some Petersburg
mississauga Gerhard hecklers family is
his tower of strength his wife Heidi and
her cooking Gerhard you carve please
that's a splash hidden hello sure that's
my job this house had initially with us
fish needn't my month my husband likes
gravy and he loves a bit of meat like
this with lots of gravy guns the
submission sank Peter spooky man that's
something I discovered in st. Petersburg
when my wife was there it was more of a
home when she left the German consul
asked me how are you managing now that
your wife is gone it health of I told
him I cooked like a cowboy fried meat
was potatoes and gravy little bit born
and he said add some beans half a can
you can eat that for days and then you
don't have to wash the pan and I was
just blown come on targeting is mostly
fun image we will it was very convenient
but depressing in the long term so I
like to be here or with my wife in st.
Petersburg dinner's ready with his four
children and six grandchildren pastor
Gerhard hegler is a staunch advocate of
family life unlike many of his
contemporaries
so a solid a physician wake of the
student revolution of 1968 we questioned
everything but then I mature and today I
would say that I hold conservative
values from the head by help there will
be a renaissance of family life venoth
hasta familia hava and a renaissance of
the evangelical faith in his church in
the mountains
after God and the family Gerhardt
hecklers other great passion is music
sunday evening is devoted to the parish
orchestra
watch the inverter why would I be I
would I be messy music is the soul of
this parish the playing doesn't have to
be perfect but it must come from the
heart
the church service is something of a
concert it brings the community together
he's been getting on depo a bit sudden I
became a Protestant gradually after high
school I wanted to work with people and
at first I thought about studying social
sciences but then I soon switched to
theology and that turned out to be my
thing
at christenings confirmations weddings
and funerals the pastor is both a father
figure and a friend he treats his
parishioners as equals without fuss or
formality
you
who'd an abend gun sets this week Roman
good evening and welcome to our evening
service this Sunday I'm season the with
a celebration of the Last Supper buzz
I'm son talk ish episode on a mudak I
inherited from my mother a curiosity
about people I have a positive interest
in them I'm curious about them I want to
share their joys and sorrows laid it's a
tile so for me pastoral work is a
wonderful way to be with people and I
wouldn't've undraped if cut with loud
note again here for instance people with
seen our dementia live upstairs while
downstairs there's a children's day care
center Smith it was founded by pastor
heckler and is used by his little
granddaughter Luka and nine other
children they go and see the elderly
people upstairs once a month that's what
the church is form to help the weak and
the sick and to be there for the young
Gerhardt heckler believes that
Christianity is not just a matter of
going to church dustless via the
lutheran church today offers people so
many different things so many that
critics say it's like a department store
with us so doc 50 goes on this isn't
give me strong Laden but I don't view it
that way though there is indeed a lot on
offer fun events [ __ ] you given what I
was young the church didn't organize
events pulled church youth days and
invite bands or show movies at swimming
pools Victor scary zaza sergeant parties
by these parties these musical events
would not have been possible but they're
great unknown done schools audit
Gerhard Hector has been invited to
church headquarters and his offered a
new job as pastor in st. Petersburg the
german lutheran church doesn't stop at
the borders of germany and he's been
invited to take this gentleman in red
with him no yes where are you going to
put him as a dusty ghost well it's the
biggest lutheran church in Russia
there's room for plenty of Martius in my
teens I will find place for him in the
sanctuary if the he'll be elevated a bit
there I remember when I was young in
churches back home they're always used
to be a picture of Luther in the pulpit
but they've all been removed he didn't
tons of them
farewell Germany a new parish 1,800
kilometers away Russia here we come st.
Petersburg
Martin Luther's new home and Gerhard
hecklers new parish is the famous aunt
peter's church right in the center of
the russian metropolis the famous
reformer makes an eye-catching figure in
the sanctuary san peter's church has a
long exciting and dramatic history the
history that is intimately connected
with the city of bazaars and of russia
as a whole
it was built in the 1830s to replace an
older and smaller Lutheran parish church
the plot of ground was a gift from Czar
Peter the second
most of the parishioners were German and
that is still the case the church is not
only used for services with its
excellent acoustics it also serves as a
concert hall with seating for an
audience of 700
originally no fewer than 3000 worshipers
could gather in this impressive building
constructed in the style of a Romanesque
Basilica with elements of Russian
neoclassicism
then on Christmas Eve 1937 the Soviets
closed the church and shot the two
pastors
in the early 1960s the building belonged
to the Communist Youth Organization the
Young Pioneers it was converted to house
a swimming pool some Petersburg
residents called it the swimming pool
church this is Sean listen ash pregnant
it is a bit shocking but on the other
hand I myself learned to swim as a child
in a beautiful 19th century building
just like this and there are still many
people living today who say I learned to
swim here and it was wonderful I
shouldn't get out we had fun as kids
again now I'm glad that it's a church
once again finish holders as we die the
kid is well did the architect whom
converted it into a swimming pool was
still alive after perestroika and he
said you should be happy it was a
swimming pool that way the church
survived other church buildings met a
worse fate
traces of the Soviet past are still
visible in the basement old tiles from
the pool
this was originally the site of the
altar
the church was resurrected in 1993 with
money from Germany the swimming pool was
covered over to create a new floor for
the church a walk through the basement
is a journey into the past sent
Petersburg's German passed the Dutch
citizens of German origin enjoyed
considerable freedom here with otherwise
they wouldn't have come Fievel they were
hard-working scientists craftsmen
doctors pharmacists teachers and
industrialists such as Zeman's and
others if the nav Siemens and of it they
made a significant contribution to st.
Petersburg and to Russia in general does
the adult and I think this wonderful
history is why we Germans have such a
good reputation among the residents of
st. Petersburg today in before I go here
fuj a hefty the wound abolish the filler
but that history was not always
wonderful these murals depict how the
Soviets banned all charges and the
German Russians were sent to Siberia
during the Second World War in Stalin's
labor army they were forced to toil
under inhuman conditions
Stalin viewed the German Russians as
potential traitors sharpie giggle and
thus i have come to realize that these
people lost the war several times over
because of the various deportations it
was mid winter and they were crammed
into cattle trucks for days on end it
must have been dreadful men women and
young people from the age of 16 I
believe were made to do forced labor for
several years [ __ ] up I'd mahone
payable on the how many of them died you
ready and I think it's awful that we
didn't even know what happened yes it
wasn't mentioned in our history books or
at school we had only English to come
without a snitch for a small chapel in
the basement is dedicated to the memory
of the victims of the Stalin regime
today's and Petersburg is a completely
different city in a completely different
country
and Germans are more popular than ever
before in the history of the two nations
both I vision it's tremendous ship
sailed by people from all over the world
it's a very vibrant and lovable city and
appending and even threaten
and it is a city that is proud of its
religious tolerance German Catholics
also have a church here there are also
Armenian Swedish and Finnish churches in
the city centre st. Petersburg is a city
with many faces and many religions
today pastor heckler is visiting his
russian ladies they are the backbone of
the parish is happier I usually sit here
seven dedicated women engaged in parish
work who also enjoy a little tea and
cake with their pastor can set that
record showing does warm welcome to you
all it's good to see you and Russian
hospitality as well I want to thank you
that said if it's worth it in the end I
would ask you to sing upon her for him
page 65 chef is Chuck I learned that an
evening class shelter for tell Shula
guillelm
aslam on galcen are the wrong the famous
poem by the German theologian Dietrich
Bonhoeffer who was executed in a Nazi
concentration camp sung in a city where
a million people died when it was under
siege by Nazi Germany during the Second
World War the hymn is sung as a warning
never to repeat those horrors but pastor
hecha is also deeply engaged in the
present and always looking to the future
I have a lot of experience in social
projects I have organized home nursing a
community of people suffering from
senile dementia and everything that
involves this is I find none of those
services in Russia but I can't say look
this is how we do it follow our example
that would be inappropriate I didn't
know science it's not my job I can only
talk about what we did and then leave it
up to my Russian audience to make of it
what they will on a 12th level or i can
pick up on an issue that's already of
some interest here I talk only about how
we dealt with because our societies deal
with such matters so differently under
the protection and Estrela on foggy pond
size of our show
game is tied up
what she had I like him very much in
fact I'm in love with him just they're
slow yeah well be or not really with all
my heart he's so cheerful an open-minded
that's very rare video because well say
we doodle doo I like his Protestant way
of doing things it's very well suited to
some Petersburg modest ascetic he's a
real Petersburg intellectual even the
critic peekaboo scandal idiom six
rosters in EG fulfills his role in
wonderfully he's truly in his element
this morning our Petersburg intellectual
is on an hour team he's on his way to
the famous volim Island in Lake Lakota
it's the site of an old monastery that
is a bastion of Russian orthodoxy the
other passengers are Orthodox Christians
it's a new experience for a German
Protestant
lancet see I didn't realize that the
lake was so big a wonderful landscape
nice people too yeah they're all
pilgrims the women are wearing scarves
found out they're going to the monastery
I imagine that they're looking for
something whenever so are we they give
me it'd be a yao simply something
different I've got mouth on birth and to
share in the life of the monastery so
far as that's possible I think it's
wonderful it just goes out
you
one of the pilgrims is Yulia who loves
the piece of vellum
Gerhard heckler and his Orthodox
companions will spend two days here in
one of Russia's most famous monasteries
they'll get to know the monks and other
pilgrims Balaam was probably founded in
the 13th century today it's more vibrant
than ever Rogers's Melanie sahaja Laura
GT you rather see cinema cemetery in
solution obras you could be seen it's
good to them this place is holy to go
out the way they chant these prayers
really touches me with the pan the fact
that holy people have lived here would
it even be there are Cave monasteries in
Greece and elsewhere but this is really
impressive occasional deliver foo and it
lives through the piety of the people i
think that's wonderful i was leaped
pusha t flemish caudillo to finish top
people come to palarm in faith and to
entrust their needs to God
what julia is 30 years old and was born
with the HIV virus we've got religion
mama mama mama Freddie Mercury yes he
prays to God mama mama very good songs
if the beginner of cyanide in there oh
my home University I like it you're
gonna help gonna live Julia town's past
a heckler her story it turns out that
they share an interest in music email
be sure I am very involved with music
dr. mosquitoes duh Cindy business visa
but you move but you asked me if I
wonder why me why do I have the virus
you I no longer ask that question I just
live and thank God that I'm still alive
what the edible okay is this chaplain
who never even done till I have learned
so much from you nisht not to ask
constantly why is something has happened
to me but to get on with life that's
great I really like to support you that
help you in your skin to beheading
and so on this summer evening in valam
passed a heckler ministers to yulia
microphone passed a heckler is back in
some petersburg it's Sunday morning and
he has his parish duties the embodiment
of summer near pasto ish pass it is
pinned I am their pastor I fit the
picture because of Eastern Orthodoxy and
the Russian tradition they have a rather
different view of pastors they put them
on a pedestal I noticed a benevolent
distance but also a great warmth con
reformation day I came an hour late to
the service while traveling in the
Baltic with my wife and daughter and the
parish breathed a sigh of relief our
pastor is back stay here is our pastor
funny because I fit the picture was my
wife and children and they received me
with great warmth I am one of the hosts
a half described using machine from as
gratitude
this end of everything will end well and
if it doesn't it's not the end
you